I think if we raise our standards,
our urban schools,
and if we can possibly attract a better,
more qualified pool of teachers down the
road,
we can do fantastic things in inner city
schools.
In our school,
University Academy for example,
we pay performance pay,
in other words,
in addition to a teacher's salary.
We have an incentive for a teacher to do
well in the classroom.
And so we attract a slightly different
type of teacher.
One Who is motivated to do well and um,
and I think it's an important when you
look at other service businesses and not
only in the United States but around the
world,
it's common for managers to get
incentives,
financial incentives to do a good job.
But we've never really done much of that
in the area of education,
which really is a service business.
And I think if we can pay teachers
competitively and attract and retain
them,
we can do great things in this gun.